what a president Truong stop aids is
gone tonight and there are growing
questions about his White House chief of
staff staff secretary Rob Porter who
announced his resignation yesterday amid
domestic abuse allegations is now
officially out today chief White House
correspondent John Roberts truck with
Porter's first wife who provided the
most damaging evidence against him the
White House today confirmed that staff
secretary Rob Porter has left after
resigning yesterday adding that the
president first learned of the
allegations against Porter on Tuesday
night he was surprised you know he like
many of us did not see that in Rob
Porter did not see what these
allegations have brought forward and so
he was surprised by it he was
disheartened by it he was saddened by it
but the spotlight today shifted to
senior staff including John Kelly and
when he first learned the allegations
against Porter he became fully aware
about these allegations yesterday I'm
not gonna get into the specifics
regarding who may have known what pieces
of information because they were all
part of an ongoing background check
investigation fully aware was he
partially aware I think we all became
aware of the news reports that emerged
on Wednesday morning and some of the
graphic images the White House wouldn't
say when Kelly or other White House
senior staff became aware of the
allegations but Colby Holderness
Porter's first wife told Fox News she
spoke to the FBI about it On January
25th 2017 more than a year ago as part
of a security clearance investigation of
Porter Holderness says she told FBI
agents about several incidents of verbal
emotional and physical abuse including a
vacation in Florence Italy where holded
it says Porter punched her in the eye
during the fight Porter's second wife
Jennifer Willoughby says she too spoke
to the FBI I told them all of the
details of my marriage including verbal
and emotional abuse and including the
incident when he pulled me out of the
shower
they were also made aware of the
protective order that I signed in in
June of 2010 and they were also made
aware of another time when I had called
the police to our home after a domestic
disturbance the White House today
repeated Porter's denials of the
accusations against him and said he was
never denied a security clearance that
the clearance investigation had not been
completed his background investigation
was ongoing he was operating on an
interim security clearance his clearance
was never denied and he resigned
Holderness told Fox News she had warned
the FBI Porter could be susceptible to
blackmail because of his history the
fact he was vetting most of the
documents that landed on the President's
desk without a full security clearance
raised eyebrows on Capitol Hill the fact
that this man operated a year without a
security clearance I didn't understand
that I'm still don't what general kill
he knew and when he knew it while the
White House won't say when chief of
staff Kelly first learned of the
allegations there was a dramatic shift
between Wednesday afternoon and
Wednesday night in the afternoon Kelley
praised Porter in a statement saying Rob
Porter is a man of true integrity and
honor and I can't say enough good things
about him he is a friend a confidant and
a trusted professional I am proud to
serve alongside him that statement was
crafted by a number of White House
officials including communications
director hope Hicks who was romantically
involved with Porter but after the
photos of a bruised and battered Colby
Holderness went public the chief of
staff did it quick about-face and a
statement saying I was shocked by the
new allegations released today against
Porter there is no place for domestic
violence in our society I stand by my
previous comments of the Rob Porter that
I have come to know since becoming chief
of staff and believed every individual
deserves the right to defend their
reputation the White House today insist
that it takes allegations of domestic
abuse seriously and acknowledges that
White House staff could have done a
better job in responding to the
revelations White House press secretary
Raja today also said that the
communications director hope Hicks
recused herself from several of the
discussions about Porter today Chris
John Roberts at the White House John
thank you